I was talking on the phone with my
brother who's stationed and Fort Bragg
and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew what on
earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew doing to
stop the spread of a pandemic bars are
already closed this doesn't make any
sense this is just something for for for
simple-minded people to express how much
they did do to combat the pandemic you
didn't do anything you infringed on
people's freedoms for no reason you have
to have a good reason for implementing
the restrictions that people are going
to implement where we move on from
Corona though and I want to obviously
talk about the book you mentioned the
stimulus before and can you just talk a
little bit about what that process is
like and when you suddenly see everybody
on every side although in this case I
think the most egregious examples were
we're by the progressives
about just all the pork they stuff in
there and all these things that have
nothing to do with helping the economy
because of coronavirus and then it held
you know it's things like you know Nancy
Pelosi happens to be on the board of the
Kennedy Arts Center and like all of
these things that we all know are
terrible and when when limited
government people see those things it's
like man if you guys can't even help us
now if you can't even do it right now
then even the little bit of the limited
part starts to become really freakin
irrelevant you know yeah as far as the
process on this particular bill and
unfortunately a lot of bills the it is a
closed group of leadership that's that's
doing that and that's for the sake of
expediency you it doesn't mean people
don't have a say there's there's a
constant conversation of and ways to get
input into there of course it's hard to
put input into a bill if you're not
really sure how the bill is is being
formed anyway our leadership there's a
previous in job of keeping us informed
in a private way so that maybe it's
maybe it's conference calls or whatever
it is so that we can say hold on we're
not in favor of this just like I was
outspoken against you know direct cash
payments I don't think then made any
sense for a lot of reasons and
and in the same way progressives and
some more populist conservatives were
against any kind of help too big to big
businesses at all you know if it's just
loans and so people still get their
voice heard on that so but the reality
is is yes a lot of this is negotiated in
in closed-door sessions and I'm not so
sure that's the wrong way because you
know you could debate it publicly on the
House floor I suppose but where would we
get and how long would that take when
when this is an emergency you know so
that that's that the whether that's good
or bad is I think truly up for debate as
far as the pork goes yeah it's
frustrating you didn't see me making a
huge fuss about it mostly because we're
talking about millions of dollars when
we passed a two trillion dollar stimulus
package so I you know I try to look at
everything through a lens of perspective
and also you know I I tried to I tried
to interpret the best of intentions from
from the people who wanted that in there
which was these these particular
organizations like the Kennedy Center
they will shed jobs if we don't fund
them because they they make their money
off of events now the frustrating part
for everybody was they still shed jobs
later like many businesses are I just
this this isn't something that like made
me angry you know and I suppose I just
wrote a whole book about not engaging in
an outrage and having some perspective
and looking a few layers deep into why
something happened as a method to sort
of temper your own emotions so you know
it's it's generally hard to get me
emotionally upset and I don't understand
it from either side of the aisle frankly
when people get emotional about things
it doesn't mean they're wrong to show
concern but I wouldn't let it keep you
up at night yeah all right so just one
more on this then what else should the
government be doing right now I mean
we're all still in lockdown you know
yesterday I went to my local hardware
store and I saw that I could buy seeds
to plant some things which I did buy but
I know that in Michigan you actually
can't buy seeds right now I mean we've
got a series of kind of crazy things and
I'm all I'm all for the
the governors and the states do and what
they want I think you mostly are as well
but there are some strange things
happening but what do you think the role
of the federal government and the states
should be right now and are they
basically working together pretty well
yeah I think the balance is about right
I think every once in a while even the
president says kind of the wrong thing
about you know whether he's talking
about forcing your reopening or forcing
a national lockdown neither is okay you
can't do it but that's up to the states
and in states like Michigan where the
governor is making up stupid rules you
they should be held accountable
I hope voters are holding I think it's
her right deeply accountable for these
completely foolish policies that are
really just based in virtue signally not
based in any actual even even two
seconds of logical thoughts it's like
what you know I was talking on the phone
with my brother who's stationed and Fort
Bragg and they have a 9:00 p.m. curfew
what on earth is a 9:00 p.m. curfew
doing to stop the spread of a pandemic
bars are already closed this doesn't
make any sense this is just something
for for for simple-minded people to
express how much they did to combat the
pandemic you didn't do anything you
infringed on people's freedoms for no
reason
you have to have a good reason for
implementing the restrictions that
people are going to implement okay so so
what's next into your question well
what's next is we have to start having a
real conversation about how to reopen
the economy alongside battling and and
reducing the risk of the pandemic and
this looks a lot like a what would
Harvard economists and and political
scientists are calling a mobilized in
transition phase I know our governor
here in Texas is going to come out with
his plan soon I think the federal
government is as well I've just written
an op-ed about it and it basically looks
like this look we tweet we have to
dispel this myth that there's a binary
choice between a perpetual lockdown and
just letting people die and the spread
of the pandemic neither of these things
are true you can do both okay and we
have to do both this is not an option we
have to do and it I think along three
factors that we
we have to be focused on testing
capacity which we're a little behind on
but I think we can rather quickly ramp
up to the right standard Public Health
capacity meaning our hospitals or
ventilators or PPE I think we're I think
we're getting to a much better place on
that and and then public education on
how to deal with it whether that's
standing six feet away from each other
wearing a mask to work you know just
making those micro changes in your life
and in your business so that we can live
alongside of pandemic for for a period
of time until there's a vaccine that's
the new normal and it doesn't involve
shutting down the economy indefinitely
we have been this is the last thing I
want to say I get really worried when we
become obsessive over the nature of the
curve and the peak those are important
data points but they're not V data
points there's other data points like
our sense of preparedness along those
three lines that I just mentioned you
know when I hear when I hear our mayor
talking about how we can't open up
Houston because we haven't reached the
peak yet I find out to be absurd because
if you put our numbers that we have here
in Houston which is very very small like
very very small we're the fourth largest
city in America we barely have any cases
you know comparatively speaking if
you've heard our numbers and place those
in New York City right now New York City
would be celebrating and they'd open up
everything if that's if that can be true
then it tells you that our logic isn't
correct as we think about what our you
know our goal posts are to open up the
economy and I just encouraging leaders
to think through this a little bit more
deeply yeah it's one of the reasons
actually that I'm kind of hopeful for
the future when we get out of this that
some of the right ideas that I think
you're writing about in this book will
break forth I mean things like states
rights like we're actually talking about
states rights right now for the first
time in this country in god I don't know
maybe since roe v wade like we've never
talked about states rights and suddenly
people are like oh governors are
supposed to do things and the president
doesn't have ultimate authority and a
whole bunch of other things so since the
book is about American resilience in the
era of outrage one thing on American
resilience related to took corona
specifically are you
worried that as this has gone on and
maybe as some of the states get back to
work and some take longer and it looks
like New York I'll take a really long
time but just the longer that we're in
our houses the longer that the economy
is shut the longer that we kind of
sputter along that thing the American
resilience that you write about here
that's the special thing we have in
America that every other country wishes
they had but the more that we sort of
just let government do things and oh oh
the peak didn't happen yet we'll stay in
our house for another month like that
we'd actually start forgetting what that
spirit of American resilience is that's
what I'm kind of I see a lot of silver
lines here as a silver linings as I just
mentioned but that's the thing I'm
worried about that over time we would
just start accepting more and more rules
and accepting that more and more experts
know what to do when perhaps they don't
and then you know the bad actors in
government that just sort of want to
control all of us yeah and those are
those are definitely reasonable fears I
think unfortunately the reality is as we
shifted towards that acceptance a long
time ago and I'm actually seeing I think
this entire experience might bring us
back to normalcy
to an extent where we do see that
experts don't have all the answers their
data is important their opinions are
important but it takes a leader to to
sift through all of those opinions and
then make a bold decision and then get
people to rally behind that decision and
mobilize if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlists all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell